so this is elemental sulfur sulfur -
lovely yellow powder it's actually if
one of the three components of gunpowder
sulfur sulfur is normally found in the
yellow form and it occurs quite widely
in nature so I have here a sample of
sulfur well it's actually a mixture of
sulfur and sand that was picked up on by
one of my colleagues on his honeymoon
you see he was thinking about chemistry
even on his honeymoon though I don't
think he told his wife that it's also
used to clean up mercury as well he knew
he bit of saffron binds with the mercury
forms mercury sulfide so that you can
sweep it away quite nicely
sulfur isn't has a rather unusual
behavior when you heat it up when you
heat up this yellow material it melts at
about 114 degrees centigrade and then as
it melts it begins first of all the
runny liquid and then as you heat it up
it goes darker and darker and thicker
and thicker so it ends up like a very
dark red Brown treacle and if you pour
this into water it then looks rather
like silly putty you get out of material
which is lighter brown which were you
can pull and mould around for several
hours till it goes hot and the reason
for this is that sulfur exists in this
form as molecules of an S 8 that's 8 -
sulfur atoms in a ring and as you heat
it up these s8 rings break and you get
longer and longer chains of molecules so
in the solution it becomes more and more
viscous and then when you pour it into
water these chains are tangled up and
exists at room temperature until
eventually they break up and they break
up and go back into their s8 4